back diamonds on your timepiece jet
planes with Dance Central spotlight
harmonics is paired at stylish connect
dancing franchise down to its most
essential elements ditching the
time-traveling story mode of Dance
Central 3 in favor of a renewed focus on
the dance routines that sit at the very
heart of the game but it's slimmed down
in some other ways too with a ten-dollar
core game serving as the gateway to a
musical storefront brimming with
reasonably priced songs to build out
your own customized library what's left
is a lean but immensely enjoyable
dancing game one that goes out of its
way to remove the barriers between you
and shaking it on the dance floor rather
than a full priced retail product dense
central spotlight is more akin to a
downloadable starter pack the core game
comes with 10 songs as genre spanning
assortment of recent hits that ranges
from the soulful pop of Lords Royals
to the infectious house rhythm of David
Guetta's titanium
every one of these songs carries on
dance Central's tradition of excellent
choreography with inventive dance
routines and lively animations bringing
each song to life but where Dance
Central spotlight differs from its
predecessors is in the amount of content
each song provides every song in the
game now offers one primary routine with
four different difficulty settings plus
two alternate routines as well as much
more strenuous cardio and strength
exercise routines
these are not mere variations they're
entirely different dance numbers as a
result each song has become its own
little rabbit hole of grooving and
shaking giving you an enormous incentive
to dive right back in as soon as the
music's over so that you can continue to
experience those new moves that said
that dancing itself is pretty much the
same as ever
you follow cue cards scrolling along the
screen attempting to mirror the game's
impossibly hip assortment of playable
characters as they shimmy and Shake in
various ways from the vivid presentation
to the consistently outstanding
choreography the mere act of dancing
makes dense central spotlights some of
the purest fun you can have on an Xbox
one
but there is one perk some quality to
the games tried-and-true formula do well
and you'll see the screen explode in a
fireworks display of light in color but
botch a move and all you get is a red
outline on your character's limbs the
same feedback system that's been used
since day one that minimalist feedback
has always been nice because of how
non-invasive it is but here it's a bit
at odds with itself
that's because dance central spotlights
progression system requires you to
unlock new dance routines by collecting
flawless performances on various dance
moves generally speaking this system is
pretty forgiving there are so many dance
moves to collect that you never really
hit a brick wall in terms of progression
but in those instances where a trickier
dance move just doesn't click with you
it's hard to tell exactly what you're
doing wrong
something missing missus you got full
attention listen let go what attention
if I get emitted I [ __ ] better
nonetheless other improvements to the
dancing experience help ease the process
of learning new moves now you can pause
mid song and jump into a quick practice
mode running through a move over and
over again until you get comfortable
with it once you've got it
you can pick right up where you left off
no need to jump out to the main menu and
launch some separate practice mode in
fact dance central spotlight is pretty
light on extraneous game modes all
together there is a neat little fitness
mode that lets you design a custom
playlist of routine types set the
overall length of your dance session and
then see how many calories you've burned
according to your height and weight but
beyond that there's the song store and
little else
even without the delightfully silly
story mode and assorted mini-games of
its predecessor then central spotlight
score offering still delivers a
tremendous value for only $10 you get an
albums worth of songs that all feature
five distinct routines to learn and
what's nice is that each song you buy
from the store which run about $2 each
with some bundles offering a small
discount all of these also offer the
same generous assortment of
choreographies so whether you end up
spending another $10 or another $40 the
library you assemble gives you plenty of
ways to shake it while simultaneously
reflecting your own musical tastes
indeed dense central spotlight feels
like an admission that sometimes you
just can't be all things to all people
rather than beef up the feature list
Harmonix has taken the opposite approach
it slimmed down the game offered way
more value and remove the obstacles
between you and just getting out there
and dancing it's a different take on
dense central but the party is just as
fun as ever turn down for what